vous allez devoir vous faire passer la
boulette puante qui sent très très très
mauvais au bout de 100 secondes vous
pose des questions sur la télé n'est
celui qui a la boule est puante au bout
de 100 secondes va devoir faire ça
la capeb
plus
devenant vous posez des questions sur la
série c'est le dernier prime celle en
fait le dernier va y avoir des morts il
des morts ayant pas du niveau pas du
tout n'inquiétait pas c'est très
sécurisé ce qu'on peut avoir une image
parce qu on entre on a préparé un donc
mieux ou tant mieux a longtemps gardé sa
cible voilà non mais c'est sécurisé do
with a kiss et utiliser le ton juste un
jeu les tester ce matin je l' ai testé
ce matin avec un pote à moi qui fais je
sais pas où il est actuellement
mais il est par ailleurs alors je vous
inquiétez pas ça se passera très bien on
est reparti on reprend up qui joue le
personnage de mélanie rinato dans plus
belle la vie plus belle je ne sais pas
laëtitia milot qui salue tirade ils sont
tous les samedis sur canal+ merde
oublier son passé à l'époque à easy de
quel pays est originaire kostine à
cordoue la fête et brésil passé passé
jean verney ce qui est un homme canon
gide est ce qu'on peut avoir une image
de gilles verdez voilà j cathédrale se
préparer regardez les tensions superman
savamment gilou vous entendez mongie new
wave vous entendiez ça va mon chéri
alain moyen-moyen rien vous le sentez
comment
et c'est super impressionnant on dirait
que je vais décoller jusque dans
l'immeuble là bas c'est un héros c'est
vertigineux comme j'ai l'impression
d'aller au bout de la rue vous êtes
notre superman mot gillou gillou avold
que vous soyez un homme canon
regardez tout ce qu'a fait gilles cette
année on vous a fait un petit us sur
gilbert d'être qui c'est qui fait ce
bruit le gigot l as et gilles verdez moi
je suis désolé c'est moi c'est toi comme
bouygues ou fait c'est mais vers véro
c'était là que l'institution yann est
très à l'aise courante à l'antenne
sally hay et la non mais c'est n'importe
quoi y compris la wii la wii je vous
demandais quelque chose oui vous êtes
sûr de vous parce qu'à que vous que vous
qui puissiez me donner confiance
gilles je vous parle je vous parle dans
un instant mon chéri d'accord vous savez
je vous aime bien anglais la mecque café
koh lanta car la france pas prévient il
nous il nous entend pas là gilles verdez
un non-remaniement en tout cas je vous
ai fait on s'est longtemps demandé l
arrêt ne va pas le faire sauter en fait
vraiment est vraiment lui faire faire
l'homme canon et puis on s'est dit ce
serait drôle de les refaire le coup un
nom génial
il croit qu'il va partir très loin et il
va acquérir comme une merde
j'aimerais qu'ils m'entendent merci
messieurs gilles gel oui ça va mon chéri
havas moyens cyril mais quand vous me
parler ça va toujours aux jaloux bon mon
vélo pas je sais que vous êtes très
flipper rentrer dans le canon mon chéri
rentrer dans le canon gilles est ce que
vous avez des mots à dire à ben notre
date dans le canon mugello super héros
tout laissez le parler j'aimerais qu'il
dise quelques mots mais ben arfa tout à
moi à qui veut peut-être si voilà je
sais que gilles vous aimez bien parler
dans ces moments là oui parce que j'aime
bien parce que votre voix me berce et ça
me donne confiance
merci que je sais que vous mmes
abandonneriez pas dans un truc comme ça
que c'est sécurisé tout ça oui je
voudrais dire à fatou et je voudrais
dire à fatou je t'aime mon bébé d'amour
je t'aime mon bébé d'amour à chaque fois
que je suis comme ça en l'air ou dans un
canon j'ai l'impression de voler vers
toi c
bonjour mon genou il avait peut-être
jaloux avant de mettre les lunettes
parce qu'elles peuvent la gêne est oui
gillou oui j'ai nous mettez les lunettes
mais télé lui et je vais vous demander
après avoir mis l'une est de dire un mot
à chacun ses lunettes de sécurité de
dire un mot à chacun des chroniqueurs
peut-être voilà dit que alors des âges
et rémois jean luc lemoine jean luc
lemoine jean luc lemoine c'est vraiment
un génie et heureusement qu'il est là
parce que mais qu'il est pas là
l'émission est nul
c'est bien tu lacombe et julien il est
bon il est bon il est bon c'est un bon
remplaçant quoi vous enora c'est une
princesse
vous savez elle l aurait fait ça mais je
pense à elle elle est courageuse oh la
la il n'aura senora quoi il aura une
oreille vfb laïb benhaim allait un peu
plus lâche porteuse complexe mais j'aime
beaucoup quand même j'aime beaucoup
quand même
j'assurais dans les bras cyril si jamais
je reviens ouais sert valérie dans mes
bras j'ai fait un énorme câlin ouais
mais bon elle a déjà vu un mec qu'elle
connaissait pas la leur gilles rigide
lequel ne va pas du tout vous manqué non
michel merci gide mon chéri ville
inquiétez pas tout va bien se passer mon
fils
un dernier mot peut-être avant de partir
à l'egypte au gym je vous aime vraiment
tous vous êtes comme ma famille vous est
adorable vous êtes tellement merveilleux
et tout ça avec vous vous êtes tous en
cadeau avec moi à l'essai par thébaux g
c'est par ces mots y aller
ouais mais les manger mais comment les
mains les mains gelées mais comment
comme ça et je garde comme ça donc comme
ça comme ça ouais utiliser ses avant
bras et ses mains pour amortir bon je ne
sois pas d'accord non dis pas ça se
passe en syrie je vous entends non mais
non je souffre publie je ne sens pas du
tout le ballon sur le plateau je ne sens
plus du tout d'accord après l'avoir
actif pendant le volant faire les uns
d'ailleurs bien rigide mais sinon j'ai
rien à faire je leur laisse aller et
retenir sa tête ou de la réception j'ai
fait attention on n'est pas trop à temps
mais je me mets ou là ici là comme ça
avec les mains de lula
ouais allez on y va et l'émincer mais
comment comme sa sortie mais ma tête
tu enlèves les chiens relevé l'échelle
allez c'est parti gillou gillou jousse
est fort au moins six ou sept ans et
révisent en vérifier les gars n'ont
aller s'il vous plaît sortait le un peu
sortez un peu gilles voilà voilà
faites ce que vous dites monsieur et
tout se passera bien que vous êtes tous
monsieur il est parti est parti de
monsieur gilles gilles à taux de change
il irrite je vous aime vous m6 rythme
aussi je vous aime
merci j alors j'ai l'on va allumer la
mèche du canot en [ __ ] du tout
oh [ __ ] gillot va allumer la mèche du
calen sayan est allumée gilles vous
allez partir dans un instant du tout je
t'aime tarifs à tout jamais pas tout
mais regardez chez vous et vous plaît
belle série regardez le soc regarde tout
j'avais pas tout
je leur dois ça va aller je peux le
revoir michel mille fois ça y est s'il
s'en va boucher y va très bien et on a
eu peur
olala ça fout les boules bon on peut
s'inquiéter pas j'allais pas vous faire
ça mon celle où je ne savais syrie on ne
savait pas du tout en fait bon je vous
embrasse fort allez venez nous rejoindre
manger ou à boire